أعتقد أن الفوائد الصحية للتمرينات الرياضية
كثيرة جدًا لدرجة أنه لا يمكن حتى قول
جلسة قديمة كهذه تعلمون أنها يمكن أن
تقلل من خطر
إصابتك بأمراض معينة تعرف أنها يمكن أن تحسن
مشكلة كتلة العضلات لديك أقل من
ربع الأمريكيين يحصلون بالفعل
على  مقدار التمرين الذي
يجب أن يحصلوا عليه ، بدأ الكثير من الأشخاص في
التحول إلى تمرينات أكثر شدة أو
تدريبًا متقطعًا عالي الكثافة ، وهذا
عندما تمارس الرياضة بشكل مكثف
لفترة من الوقت ، عادةً ما تقل عن
دقيقة ، خذ استراحة صغيرة ، قم بذلك مرة
أخرى وأنت تفعل  هذه الدورة مرارًا
وتكرارًا لمدة 30 إلى 45 دقيقة ، فإن
الحجة الكبيرة للتدريب المتقطع عالي الكثافة
هي أنه ربما لم
يساعد فقط ملف التمثيل الغذائي الخاص بك بشكل عام
على إنقاص الوزن يساعدك على بناء
القدرة على التحمل لقلبك ورئتيك ،
ولكنه قد يفعل ذلك  أفضل مما لو كنت
تقوم بالتدريبات المنتظمة ذات الفترات المنخفضة
ولكن إليك قاعدة عامة
يجب أن تتذكر أن الحد الأقصى لمعدل ضربات القلب
هو عادة 220 ناقص معدل ضربات القلب  بالنسبة
لي ، هذا صحيح في حوالي 170 لا
تريد أن تدع التمرين الذي تتجاوزه
حقًا هذا النطاق أولاً وقبل كل
شيء يحتمل أن يكون خطيرًا
ثانيًا على الأرجح أنك لا
تحصل على فوائد التمرين بقدر
ما ستحصل عليه بخلاف ذلك  لذا ، سواء كان ذلك
تمرينًا شاقًا أو تمرينًا معتدلًا ،
تأكد فقط من ممارسة بعض التمارين أثناء
التعرق والتي من المحتمل أن تساعدك على
العيش حتى 100 شخص.